Have you ever started learning a
language and then a few weeks or months
down the line you just tell yourself,
that nagging voice of yours keeps
telling you that there are simply too
many beautiful languages to be learned
in this world? And then you end up
learning many and achieving nothing. Hi
my name is Luca from Luca from LucaLampariello.com and today I'm going to talk about
the diabolical tendency that we all have
to spread ourselves thin and how to deal with it.
The Internet has changed
everything; now whenever we want to, we
can just go on the internet surf the
internet and find all the resources we
want, if we want to read, write, speak
listen, whatever you want, but the problem
is that that this wealth of information
has actually further exacerbated the
tendency that we all have to spread
ourselves thin - "jack of all trades master
of none", as they say in English. So, one
thing that has really made a difference
in my journey of learning 14 languages
has been that I stick to one
language whenever I start learning it. So,
whenever I just set a date, I tell myself
that for at least eight, nine months or
twelve months I will stick to that
language, and my piece of advice is to
create a very strong reminder that you
want to stick to that language no matter
what happens, no matter which "language
sirens" are going to call you, and I have
found out that having post-its on your
desktop or the place where you learn
every day is great, or also on places
that are visible, such as your
refrigerator -  you can stick a post-its
post-its are saying "learn just this
language" or maybe just a flag
representing the language that you
are sticking to, this is really important
because the temptations are going to be
many, numerous and you don't want to fall
into the trap of starting to learn
another language.
The reason why sticking to just one
language for a period of time has made a
huge difference is that it allows me to
develop a "language core". A language core
is a an entanglement of many things -
experiences, sounds, words, people - and
obviously it requires time. Imagine for
example dating five girls or five guys
at a time. Sure,  you have a lot of fun but
the reality is that since we have only
so much time
you're literally spreading yourself thin
you're giving yourself to five people a
little bit and then at the end you
achieve nothing, you're just dating
people but you're not building a
relationship and building a relationship
with the language is very similar to
building a relationship with a person: at
the beginning you're a little bit
uncomfortable because you don't know
that person but then it grows on you
with time you get to know that person
you get to know yourself through that
person the same thing with language and
languages so keep that in mind and think
that you need then you need at least
nine months to twelve months to develop
a relationship before moving on possibly
to other relationships.
Another key reason why sticking to just
one language for a certain period of
time is so effective is that it takes
time to build habits, so not only
building habits in terms of learning but
also in terms of when to learn, how to
learn, your overall approach so it's
important that if you just apply this to
one language it allows you to build
habits for that specific language that
on top of that you can also reuse and
apply to other languages. It's a matter
of time, energy, habits. You have to
remember that the most important secret
- if there is one secret in language
learning - is learn every day. If you're
trying to learn multiple languages at
the same time and you are just dabbling in
many languages, you run the risk of
literally spreading yourself thin,
dispersing your energy and at the end of
the day you won't develop the habits
that you need to literally "make it
happen", you always have to remind
yourself the language learning is a
marathon, it takes time, you can't run 40
be 40, be 3, be 2 marathons at the time,
and this is a very important point to keep in mind.
So, here you have it. I hope
you like this video I found it useful
and remember if you want to be serious,
if you are serious about learning
languages and you want to reach fluency
in one language and move on and learn
another one, it is really important to
stick to one language at a time and form
a core especially because the benefits
of speaking a language fluency are immense,
and once you speak a language fluently,
not only you're going to enjoy the
process much more, but this allows you to
create the mental and the physical and
the cognitive space to learn other
languages.
If you want to know about NOT dabbling with languages please click on the link in the description box and
you will be able to read and listen to a
very cool article that my friend and
colleague Kevin Morehouse has put
together on this fascinating topic.
Thank you for listening and see you very very soon here on YouTube